[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live would you like to hear an
amazing fact Matt trophy gee Matt truth
is II have you heard that word before
Matt rafidhi is a rare behavior more
commonly found in spiders were a
creature feeds on its own mother
now most mothers would do anything for
the children but in the case of some
arachnid mothers like The Velvet desert
spider crab spiders they make the
ultimate sacrifice they offer themselves
as prey to their offsprings as an
essential step to awaken their hunting
instincts and provide a final meal at
first the baby spiders feed on a milk
like liquid that the mother exudes when
she eventually runs out of milk the
mother circles the youngsters tapping
and vibrating the web calling in the
5280 starving spiderlings they swarm in
a frenzy somehow aware that when the web
vibrates it's time to eat the mother
then presses herself into her babies
offering herself as a final feast she
makes no attempt to escape as her young
eventually pierce her soft abdomen and
with their mouths they gradually devour
her you know the Bible talks about a
parent that offers their body as food so
the children can survive stay with his
friends were going to learn more as
amazing facts brings you this edition of
Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
says that's one eight hundred four sixty
three seventy to ninety seven now let's
join our host pastor Doug Batchelor
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and if you have a Bible
question that's why we do this program
we love to talk about the Word of God
and lines are wide open I'm all dressed
up and ready to go but if you don't ask
a Bible question there's nothing to do
it's a free phone call here's the number
800 god says eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven brings your
Bible question into our studio but I'll
say it again eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven if you've got
any question about the Word of God or
the Bible we are alive this is our first
Bible answers live broadcast in 2018 and
I invite you to give us a call pastor
Ross is off tonight but with our crew in
the studio we're gonna press on and
begin with a word of Prayer
loving Lord we are so thankful for the
gift you give us in your holy word and
we just pray that you'll bring it to
life if there's any questions our
listeners have had about the Word of God
I pray that they'll call those in now
quicken our minds with your spirit and
help us to find the answers in your word
that we might be transformed by its
power we thank you and pray in Jesus
name well friends uh you know some
people probably cringe a little bit when
you talk about spiders and then if you
compound that by talking about baby
spiders eating their mother then you're
really cringe but when you think about
it it's really the mother sacrificing
herself she's a hundred times bigger
than any of her babies and she offers
herself because she knows they're
starving several of these are desert
spiders and there's just no liquid out
in the desert and it makes me think of
an interesting statement that Jesus
makes now we all know 666 is a
spookie number but did you know that
there's a verse in the Bible John
chapter 6 verse 66 where it says after
Jesus said something his disciples
turned back from following him what was
it that Jesus said that's so troubled
his disciples that many would abandon
him
here it is John chapter 6 verse 53 jesus
said to them most assuredly I say to you
unless you eat the flesh of the Son of
Man and drink his blood you have no life
in you whoever eats my flesh and drinks
my blood has eternal life and I will
raise him up in the last day now you
might be thinking well that is kind of
tough because you know first of all
according to clean and unclean animals
humans would not be in the clean
category we don't have fins or scales
and neither do we have clothes or true
the cud and the Bible also says you're
not supposed to eat blood so for a Jew
to eat a human cannibalism would be the
worst thing and yet jesus said you must
eat my flesh and drink my blood we know
whenever we celebrate the Lord's Supper
he said this symbolically saying that we
need to be believing through faith in
the Gospel story that we need to be
reading the Word of God that is that
bread that came down from heaven Christ
is called the bread of life Jesus is
called the word and here we are at the
dawn of a new year friends do you have a
devotional life Jesus didn't say well
you know you'll be a little better off
if you eat my flesh and drink my blood
he said unless you do this you have no
zero life in you if you're a Christian
or you say you're a Christian and you're
not spending time reading his word or
time in prayer time practicing your
faith then are you really eating his
flesh and drinking his blood are you
really
partaking of Christ and filling your
life with Jesus through prayer you're
soaking him up you know unless you do
this he says you have no life we must be
absorbing Christ and abiding in Christ
and drinking from that living water
otherwise we're gonna just stay thirsty
we're gonna stay hungry but if we hunger
and thirst after righteousness and
Christ is our righteousness
we will be filled we have a special
offer we'd like to make available and we
figure at the beginning of a new year is
a great time to do this it's a book I
wrote about the Bible it's called the
ultimate resource and all you gotta do
is call this number and we'll send it to
you like to encourage everybody here at
the dawn of this new year you've got a
threshold to make a new beginning and
just really be feasting on the word so
you can be strong in the Lord the number
for the free offer eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and
that's for the offers that we mentioned
from night tonight 808 three five six
seven four seven is for the free offer
and just tell them you're listening to
Bible answers live and you're requesting
the book the ultimate resource if you're
in a hurry you'd like to read it online
we'll let you download it for free and
it's in a few different formats go to
amazing facts dot o-r-g amazing fact so
our G and you'll see a little tab it
says free book offers and we'll we'll
want you to read that and download it
call we'll mail it to you either way
read it share it with a friend and with
that we're gonna go to the phones and
talk to Michael who is calling from
Florida Michael welcome to Bible answers
live all right hello yes you're on thank
you for your patience okay yeah oh yeah
my question is I understand the question
might be it probably a little difficult
to answer just it was interation was a
short phone call only because of how
broad I think the subject might be but
then again I don't know I was going to
ask does the Bible say anything on how
to address I guess with a waning faith
as in like if one begins to find
themselves becoming more skeptical if
not unbelieving of the Bible tenants
especially in lieu of the fact that to
speak personally my own a lot of my
upbringing of the Christian I didn't
think about it until probably recently
that a lot of these things that I just
wrote English took us truth as the
authority of the Bible and another
belief
I was really just take I almost feel
like I was taking them more of authority
of the people that leaves me and actual
personal conviction and oh yeah and is a
very general way to address because in
multiple ways I can say my mind is a
little skeptical but yeah I don't know
is there anything that I won that can
help to address those sort of questions
and it's a good question you know how do
you know that you've got real faith and
you're not just believing the Bible
because you sort of raised in a
Christian environment now I was raised
in an agnostic or atheist environment so
for me I needed to really discover it
for myself but I think every believer
needs to really discover that the Bible
is true for themselves now a few verses
one is in Romans chapter 10 where it
tells us faith comes by hearing and
hearing by the Word of God you know when
people heard Jesus speak the word came
alive jesus said in John chapter 6 the
words I speak to you they are spirit and
they are life and so if you're reading
the Bible for yourself you can't just go
to church you can't just say I'm a
Christian and say a little prayer before
you eat and say well that means I'm I've
had my devotions if you really take time
and read the Bible the Bible will keep
you from sin or sin will keep you from
the Bible that's what Dwight Moody said
and I found that's true and the Bible is
a powerful book in that the words are
supernatural there's real life in them
now if you're neglecting your devotions
pray prayer and reading the word
practicing your faith your faith is
going to start being challenged and in
fact the devil it's going to challenge
the faith of every believer so if you
were the devil wouldn't you want to
diminish people's faith so he's just
he's doing his job but you don't want to
lose faith because be without faith the
Bible says it's impossible to please God
and that's in Hebrews chapter 6
so our hebrews chapter 11 and so I do
the book that I mentioned tonight is a
free offer Michael you would enjoy it
it's called the ultimate resource it'll
give you a lot of evidence on how you
can strengthen your faith
and discover for yourself that the
things in the Bible are true even
accurate and scientific would you like
that free offer yeah all right just give
you can call the number which is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven ask for the book on the ultimate
resource or go to the website amazing
facts dot o-r-g and click where it says
tabs you can even probably do the google
the ultimate resource Doug Batchelor
you'll find the book there and read that
it'll encourage you also we have a
website called Bible universe where you
can sign up on a Bible study course that
is guaranteed to strengthen your faith
that's called Bible universe com thank
you for your call Michael appreciate it
next we're gonna be talking to Joe in
Mississippi Joe thank you for waiting
you are on the air with Bible answers
live hey thanks for taking taking my
call oh yeah
yes it's kind of funny that my question
builds on the last callers question in a
way but in a more of a broad body type
question there's a statement or a there
is a passage that's in Philemon chapter
one courses only chapter but verse six
Paul is writing to him saying I pray
that the Fellowship of your faith may
become effective through the knowledge
of every good thing that is in you for
Christ's sake and going over that verse
there I've been warning to someone to
explain that a little bit to me give me
an idea of what Paul is trying to get
across
and what that affects it effective
fellowship looks like in the church all
right very good good question
book of Philemon is a short book it's an
amazing story Paul is writing to a
believer Philemon regarding a slave
named Anessa mossad run away from
Philemon while an SMS was in Rome he
meets Paul he's converted he becomes a
Christian and Paul said you know you
stole from your master and you ran away
you really ought to bring back
the things you stole and confess and now
Paul is writing a letter to Philemon
saying show mercy on him don't forget
how much God has forgiven you you should
forgive him and embrace him not as a
slave but as a brother
and so then Paul is telling to find
liman he says if you do this the
communication I'm reading verse six in
the New King James Version are no
actually I'm reading in the King James
it says if you do this the communication
of your faith may be effectual by the
acknowledging of every good thing in
other words the witness that you will
have in your community by showing that
you will embrace a person who has
wronged you
will acknowledge every good thing that
is in you in Christ Jesus
Paul is encouraging Philemon to show
mercy on an SMS to embrace him as a
brother to forgive his stealing and I
know the whole slavery issue is a
difficult subject but and he's saying
this is gonna help your witness for
others that's what he means by the
communication of your faith or I think
in some versions it says it a little bit
different it says that the sharing of
your faith in the new King James Version
may become effective when people see us
live out our religion our faith the
sharing of our faith is much more
effective they see it's real does that
make sense yes your walk your talk talks
and your walks talks but you talk talk
loud and you walk talk that's right
that's good boy I tell you they know how
to say that they're in Mississippi you
got it right hey well thank you Joe and
I think I think you'll enjoy the free
offer tonight if you'd like that that's
simply called the ultimate resource you
can download it at amazing facts dot
o-r-g or we'll send it to you just call
808 three five six seven four seven now
that does free up another line and if
you want to call with your Bible
question the studio line once again is
800 god says call with your question
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven if it rings a minute be
patient we've got two or three
volunteers picking up the phones and
they'll take your call and line it up in
a talk next to
Phil who's calling from New York Phil
you're on the air with Bible answers
live okay great first of all thank you
very much for taking my call
secondly I'm impressed with your
knowledge yeah I taught high school math
but if I knew math as well as you know
the Bible I could have taught it in MIT
well I'll just be glad I'm not teaching
math right now because I didn't do very
well with that okay my question is this
is the question that different Christian
denominations answer very differently
I'm interested in your opinion however
did Mary the mother of Joseph have
natural children subsequent to the birth
of Jesus or did you remain a virgin all
of her life and not have any other
children I believe that she had one
child and that was Jesus I don't believe
she remained a virgin because the Bible
says Joseph knew her not until and the
word knowing means intimately right you
know Adam knew his wife and had a baby
so we know what that means but it says
that Joseph knew her not until the child
was born even though they were legally
married she remained a virgin until
after the birth of Christ and there's no
reason in the world to believe that
through the subsequent years they were
married they didn't have normal marriage
relationship now the other children that
are mentioned as Jesus brothers and
sisters it mentions four boys by name
that are brothers and then it just says
he also had sisters we don't know what
their names were but there were at least
one or at least two of them because it
says plural they were probably the
children of Joseph by a prior marriage
because when Jesus is dying on the cross
he commits the care of his mother to the
Apostle John and not one of his siblings
which would seem like the natural thing
to do but probably Joseph had had some
children it wasn't uncommon for women to
die in childbirth or to die young in
those days and man might go through a
couple of wise as Abraham did before
they died so I think that based on the
Scriptures the other thing is Jesus was
probably the youngest of Joseph's
children because the firstborn would
never leave the family biz
and become an a tenor at preacher the
firstborn always sort of had the family
responsibility and so for that reason
and a few others were pretty sure that
Jesus was the only child of Mary but
Joseph and Mary probably did have normal
marriage relationship afterward okay
thank you so very much for that answer
thank you feeling good question
appreciate that and we do have another
line open eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven with your Bible
questions and with that we're gonna keep
on going and we're gonna talk next to
may on am I saying that right are uh
Marjorie there we go sorry the font was
small Marjorie in where are we Michigan
Marjorie in Michigan your question hi I
have been having some horrific
nightmares and to the point where I have
been calling for help from a psychiatric
phone call anyway here's my question did
Satan have a wife my quick answer would
be no and the reason I give is because
Jesus said Satan is a fallen angel his
name used to be Lucifer and he kind of
got the name Satan which simply means
adversary after he rebelled Jesus said
angels neither marry nor are they given
in marriage angels do not procreate like
humans there'd be no reason for Satan to
have a wife now I am aware growing up
you know the whole Rosemary's Baby
scenario where the devil is going to
have a relationship and that they this
baby becomes the Antichrist there's
several variations of this but there's
nothing about that in the Bible that's
just a myth well that was just a
terrible nightmare Bible is pretty clear
there's not a thing in the Bible that
says Satan has wife but the devil is
trying to destroy the Bride of Christ
which is the church yes and you read
about that in and that's why the devil
is probably haunting you a little bit
with nightmare
it's not usually the devil in person he
works through his fallen angels and you
know Satan didn't fight well yeah then
the devil didn't fall by himself the
Bible says in Revelation chapter 12
Satan and his angels were cast out and
Jesus calls them demons they're called
evil spirits you know sometimes we think
of them as ghosts or goblins and and
yeah these are just fallen angels they
used to be good holy angels and they
rebelled along with Lucifer and God
often works and saves us and answers
prayers through angels and the devil he
tries to torment and tempt and that
bother us but don't be discouraged jesus
promised Margery is greater is He that
is in you than he that is in the world
now I've got a free offer for you and if
you will simply go to the amazing facts
website we've got a lesson that says did
God crease it create a devil it'll tell
you about where the devil came from and
how to overcome him and it's a lesson
called did God create a devil you can
download that at amazing facts we will
send you a free copy if you call the
resource number it's a different number
from the other that number is
888-259-3826 down because um this is
saying is the god of living not the god
of the dead a good question and well you
know is a person when when a person
sleeping
are they alive or dead Dan dead when the
person sleeps they're dead when you go
to sleep tonight will you be dead or
will you still be like not not know I'm
talking about literal literal sleep when
I fall asleep am I still alive yeah okay
Abraham is sleeping in the Lord the
Bible says David died and slept with his
fathers jesus said my friend Lazarus is
asleep and so when believers died their
next conscious thought is the
resurrection and being in the presence
of the Lord but we know the
resurrections in the future and hasn't
happened yet so we might rejoice when we
know a loved one has died in faith
because their next thought is the
presence of the Lord but it hasn't
happened yet because the judgment hasn't
happened the resurrection hasn't
happened so Abraham is not there yet
with his new glorified body
Abraham is sleeping in the Lord Bible
tells us that Abraham slept with his
fathers and he's still asleep when when
do they wake up you read in 1st
Thessalonians the Lord Himself will
descend from heaven with a shout the
voice of the Archangel the Trump of
Christ then the dead in Christ will rise
when the Lord descends and the trumpet
blows then Paul says in a moment will be
changed these corruptible bodies are
replaced by immortal bodies and that's
when the resurrection happens so is
Abraham alive yes is he but he's
sleeping the sleep of death so to speak
yeah and this and all that I mean I
totally believe that too but only about
this creature I have you know a doubt
when somebody asked me a question
you know our answer to you no because
because God's Jesus says I'm the God of
Abraham Isaac and Jacob he's not the god
of the dead but of the living Abraham
Isaac and Jacob you know the the
Sadducees believed that when you die
that that was the end of your existence
Jesus is saying no that's not the end of
their existence they're still going to
be resurrected
and so are they walking around heaven
now no but will they be in the
resurrection yes Abraham died though
over 3,000 years ago but does it seem
like 3,000 years for him no the next
thought Abraham has is as soon as he
dies resurrection
there's no consciousness of time for him
but we live in you know we live in a
world where we have the dimension of
time and we know that Christ has not
come the resurrection hasn't happened
yet that's why on a lot of Christian
graves it says rest in peace they're
resting hey thank you very much by the
way Thomas of you or anyone else wants
to have our study on that just call the
resource line 883 five six seven four
seven ask for the study are the dead
really dead are the dead really dead and
you'll be blessed we do have another
line open if you have a Bible question
and we're gonna take one more question
before the break and that's 804 six
three seven two nine seven with your
Bible questions and with that we're
gonna talk to David who's listening on
line six but he didn't know that calling
from Michigan David you're on the air
with Bible answers live pastor dog
pleasure to speaking with you
likewise there's a scripture in 1st
chronicles 21 says and Satan stood up
against Israel and provoked David to
number Israel while I was thinking about
this question I remember there's also a
similar scripture in 2nd Samuel 24 but
in this Lord moved David to number
Israel so my question is is what is the
significance of having Israel to be
numbered or Satan for Satan to do this
and is it correct for me to think that
this has happened more than a few times
in history that there's been this rising
up to number Israel for some specific
purpose yeah I you know the way I
understand this and it makes sense to me
is that here you've got David he's at
the zenith of the kingdom he had started
out as a lonely shepherd boy who went
out by himself against the Giant and
then David
you know starts out with 400 mighty men
and the later 600 mighty man he takes on
the whole Philistine army and David knew
about Jonathan who just with Jonathan
and his armor-bearer they killed 20
Philistines David had been reminded over
and over through his life that it's not
the multitude of soldiers that defeats
the enemy it's faith now David instead
of trusting in God he wants to see how
big his military forces and this was a
lack of faith and so you know God
basically removed his protection so that
the devil could have a chance to tempt
David in the area pride and David would
realize that he he was losing faith in
God so it kind of revealed his own heart
to him and then Israel was punished for
this because Israel was trusting and how
big they become how powerful how
successful have victorious and they got
with newest protection and they were
they were judged they were humbled for
that so that was a matter of fact if you
read on in the story you'll read where
David's general job when David said go
to number Israel job said why do you
want to do that we've always trusted God
why do you want to know the number you
know and the command the Bible says was
up Horan to JoVE the general he didn't
want to do it because he knew that was
not God's will so I think that's what's
at the heart of it hey thank you very
much for your question David we're gonna
take a break in just a moment here don't
go away friends we got more Bible
questions you can call in with your
Bible question we still got 30 minutes
to go be right back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
life's a curious thing I mean just when
things seem under control wham you're
hit with something new your marriage is
good
suddenly it's on the brink of divorce
that job's great and then it's gone and
so's your life savings you feel healthy
Danny a doctor gives the bad news what's
coming next you could look to the stars
but they don't have the answers but this
does the prophecy Study Bible by amazing
facts this Bible's special
it's 27 personal study guides lead you
on a life-changing journey through God's
Word to discover real answers to life's
questions from health and relationships
to family and the future the hopes in
here get your amazing facts prophecy
Study Bible today by calling
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evenings
program call 888-814-3923 office is off
tonight yeah but we're gonna get right
back to the phones and I'm gonna be
talking to Wilford is that right
calling from New York hi how are you hi
thank you for your call and your
question tonight what question is pastor
doug the bible says absent from the body
is present with the Lord when Lazarus
died why did Jesus have to go to the
grave there is him it's absent from the
body of the Lord
well when Paul says that absent from the
body is present with the Lord he just
means that you know when you die your
next conscious thought is the
resurrection it hasn't happened yet but
you have no consciousness in death have
you ever had a good night's sleep where
you went to bed and you may have slept
six or eight hours but it felt like this
a few minutes
for those who die in the Lord their next
thought is the resurrection it's instant
for them yeah you know even if you have
a troubled night's sleep it seems a
little longer but when you die that
sleep is is no dreams it's a dreamless
sleep and so Lazarus was not in heaven
yet think about it for a second if if
Lazarus was in heaven and Jesus brought
him back from heaven would Lazarus be
happy to go from a glorified body back
to a physical body I wouldn't be
thanking Jesus for that so Lazarus was
in the grave there are about 12
resurrections in the Bible Wilford in
all 12 of those resurrections none of
the people resurrected ever said I was
in heaven and you brought me back or I
was in hell and you saved me from hell
none of them ever comments on knowing
anything because you read in
Ecclesiastes chapter 9 the livigno
they'll die but the dead know not
anything
and so Hezekiah said the dead do not
praise the Lord no nobody's its dead is
thinking anything it's the resurrection
when that happens then we are with the
Lord that's when the Lord descends from
heaven then the resurrection happens and
you can read about that also in 1st
Corinthians chapter 15 it says that the
resurrection happens with the coming of
the Lord so I've got that free book I
mentioned a moment ago I'll be happy to
send you a copy on our the dead really
dead and it talks about things like your
question about Lazarus thank you like
that free study guide yeah just you can
either go to the amazing facts website
or if you call this number we'll send
you one for free eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven ask for
the study guide are the dead really dead
it has all the scriptures on that
subject and thank you thank you very
much Wilford for your call all right
we're going to be talking on line number
eight talking to Oh who's on it just the
number disappeared line eight is it mo
hi hey there you go
yes sir your question I understand that
Muslims believe that only the Quran and
Arabic is God's Word I believe the Bible
is God's Word but our translations the
Hebrew Bible in the King James English
or the New Testament King James II was
which which I believe is divinely
inspired when our translation is God's
Word that's a good question
the word of God's inspired you would
want to stay as close to the original
message in a translation there are some
translations that have butchered the
Bible theoretically I could translate a
Bible you could translate a Bible we
could print it and you could call yours
the MOE Bible I could call mine the
Batchelor Bible and I could do a very
poor job so that it's a corruption of
the word of God
just like you know you can go to a
church where the preacher is filled with
the spirit and you can go to a church
where the preachers not converted and he
is just totally destroying the Word of
God and teaching false doctrines there
may be some truth mixed in but he's
twisting things so there are some very
bad Bible translations that twist things
but most of them have so much of the
truth still intact that a person can be
converted and saved through it you know
what I'm saying and I also know that
poor translation has caused suffering in
Hebrew Bible says I don't know about you
should not suffer which to live but the
word the Hebrew word is not which it's
suddenly like an astrologer or some a
medium yeah and they I mean Salem witch
trials these poor girls were terrible I
know that was awful a poor translation
and there are many times when the Bible
has been poorly interpreted or
translated and people have suffered
they've suffered from you know there's
some false doctrines out there because
of a bad translation
and I you know I can think of several
cases of that where just as one little
word that somebody got wrong and it
twists the meaning an example would be
when Jesus is talking to the thief on
the cross Jesus said to the thief verily
I say to you today you will be with me
in paradise
but the translators put the comma before
the word today and it reads verily I say
to you , today you'll be with me in
paradise well that causes problems for
people the thief was not in paradise
with Jesus that day because Jesus was
not in paradise that day when Mary went
to worship him Sunday morning he said do
not cling to me I've not yet ascended to
my father so one little comma can mess
people up see what I'm saying yeah I
know Jay and the only one I love and
trust of the King James I think the
translators were divinely inspired I
really do well there's no question the
King James Bible is a masterpiece of
literature that it's had more influence
on the English language in the history
of the world than probably any other
document and it's my favorite
translation but God there are some other
good translations that came from what
they call the Textus Receptus or the
receive text and you know like the New
King James or the new American Standard
that are very close to the original hey
thank you very much I appreciate your
call MO and by the way you would enjoy
the free offer tonight or that a book
I've written on the Bible called the
ultimate resource alright and with that
let me see who has been waiting
patiently we can talk next to Jim who is
calling from I don't know where you're
calling from Jim you're on the line with
Bible answers live hi pastor Doug how
are you good how are you
looks like I'm first minute River
California it's a Mendocino in the
redwood coach yeah I know that 707 area
code exactly correct I'm reading for max
this 28 31 to 35 right in there and it
says you shall make the robe of the
ephod all of blue and then it goes down
at 34 says a golden bell and a
pomegranate a golden bell and a
pomegranate all around the hem of the
robe and this is for Aaron I understand
the golden bells so that people would
know that he was still alive and walking
around in the most holy place what's the
purpose or symbolism of the pomegranates
yeah good question question the
pomegranate was sort of like a very
special fruit in the desert it grows in
desert regions it's interesting that it
you know right there in the very white
pulp of this fruit is a blood-red fruit
and it was sort of a symbol for the
blood of and the priests were always
dealing with that but that blood that
you eat a pomegranate it's a very
healthy fruit they say it's got all
kinds of medicinal value - pomegranate
juice exactly so they knew that back
then and it was a symbol of similar to
the grape a symbol of the the blood of
Christ okay that's the best answer I've
heard from others when I've talked with
some scholars because I had the same
question why a pomegranate I make her
been a banana man why why a palm coulda
been a date today I mean they ain't have
bananas back then because bananas
actually hybrid but you know why the
pomegranate it was a desert fruit that
managed in very dry climates to still
retain moisture in life and so it was
sort of a sacred you know the idea of
seeds though these seeds can be planted
as possibly the word but I've not found
any scriptural proof of that and so in
the bells of the sound that sound is
could be the word being spread out
pomegranate is the seeds which are
planted by the Holy Spirit I just didn't
know
you know you're making me want to go
look that up tonight and see if I can
learn more about it because I it is a
good question probably something in
Hebrew history would give us more
insight into that hey thank you very
much James for your question and it's a
stimulating question and one of those
I'm gonna have to dig a little deeper
into why the pomegranate all right let
me see Oh
Thomas has been waiting a long time
we're gonna talk to Tom
who's calling from Detroit Michigan Tom
you're on the air with Bible answers
live yes good a good evening passed the
first time caller I'd like to know in
Genesis when man was building the Tower
of Babel why was that a threat to God
that they were building the Tower of
Babel well of course you know you can't
hurt God so it wasn't a threat in that
sense but don't write I knew God said
you know it was a rebellion against God
for one thing God told Adam and Eve and
he told Noah go be fruitful multiply
disperse and fill the earth well instead
of dispersing they were congregating in
one spot and they were building
basically the tower was something of an
idol they were making a man-made
religion they weren't sure God was not
going to flood the world again they
thought we can run to the tower and save
ourselves and the Lord was saying look
that's not I made the world as a garden
I want you to go and to fill the earth I
didn't want you to congregate and create
this new religion they notice they don't
build the tower to make a name for God
it says they built the tower by the way
this is Genesis 11 to make a name for
themselves and we think Nimrod who was a
mighty hunter against the Lord is the
way the original reads Nimrod was at the
heart of that so they were building up a
whole religion kind of an opposition to
God
Babylon later became known as the
opposite of Jerusalem Babel and is the
name that is used in Revelation for this
false religion which he's called the
mother of harlots
so this first kingdom of Babel and
that's where we get the word babbling
when they couldn't understand each other
we say that they were babbling so it
represented the confusion of tongues God
withdrew his spirit when you get to Acts
chapter 2 and God pours out his spirit
now instead of their tongues being
confused God gives them the gift of
tongues so others can understand and it
sounds like he's reversing the curse of
Babylon anyway I hope that helps a
little bit and Tom I do have a book I've
got an article actually that talks about
Babylon you can even download my video
on just typing Doug Batchelor Babylon on
YouTube and you'll find it there as well
and the hope that helps a little thank
you for your patience and your good
question um okay we're talking next to
as Adam Moses all right that's a
question about Moses is this Henry yeah
hello hi and your question what's a New
Year to you
hey likewise thank you very much before
Cleopatra or after before ya Moses lived
about 14 80 BC Cleopatra lived during
the time of Julius Caesar which is more
like 60 BC so they were separated by
over a thousand years when Moses came
first
oh absolutely yes yeah Moses lived
during the time of Ramses which was many
many years hundreds of years before
Cleopatra came around well before no
cleopatra lived during the time of
Julius Caesar she married Octavian well
you know and Julius Caesar both and that
that was around 60 BC if my memory
serves me right uh but I'm quite sure
it's in that ballpark
Moses was over 1400 BC so you know I've
got a Bible timeline you can go online
if you can get online and and just type
in Bible history I don't have a computer
you said this she married Octavian she
married Julius Caesar and Augustus
Caesar a guest has changed
named to Augustus I believe from
Octavian or Mark Anthony rather sorry I
know now getting except she married
Julius Caesar and Mark Antony or she had
affairs with them both I don't know if
she married him I know I see women walk
at me but Octavian he kept he wanted he
wanted to bring her into room and
welcome back over Terry or something and
she killed herself
yeah Octavian ended up becoming against
the Caesar it's just a change of name
but there was Mark Anthony and Julius
Caesar anyway long time before Moses no
yeah and paid the paid the price too he
reigned for forty years she would have
been better off with him than with that
Julius Caesar hey Thank You Henry for
your good question
I appreciate that and with that we're
gonna go talk to Glenn who's waiting
patiently calling Bible answers like me
Glenn you're on the air give me anyone
pastor Doug happy New Year to you a
couple of times tonight you've mentioned
that the the dead remain asleep and
until the the Saints remain asleep until
the resurrection well that being said
how do you explain Matthew 17 I believe
it is 17 3 we're both Moses and Elijah
meet with Jesus Peter and John on the
Mount of Transfiguration yeah there are
there are some who have been resurrected
for instance the Bible tells us that
Enoch walk with God and God took him
enix in heaven the Bible tells us that
Elijah went to heaven and a fiery
chariot and you'll read in the book of
Jude verse 9 there's only one chapter in
Jude Jude verse 9 it tells us about the
resurrection of Moses that God sent
Michael who raised Moses and the devil
tried to stop him saying you know he's
mine and Michael said the Lord rebuke
thee and so there's no question that
there are some in heaven Moses as their
Elijah's there not only Moses Elijah
Enoch but at the resurrection of Jesus
it says there was a great earthquake and
this is Matthew 28 I'm pretty sure there
was a great earthquake and the graves of
many of those who slept around Jerusalem
notice it says the dead are sleeping
there
doesn't say all it says many came out of
their graves and they ascended to heaven
when crisis ended so he took some of
them he didn't take them all because you
read in Acts chapter 2 Peter says David
is dead and buried and his tomb is with
us to this day
then in Acts chapter 2 you read on it
tells us David is not ascended to heaven
so Peter cannot be any more clear in his
sermon when he says David is dead buried
not in heaven so not everybody obviously
is in heaven there's a resurrection
coming moses is there elijah so we're
we're to believe that there's at this
point in time in history through all the
thousands and of years that there's only
a handful of people in heaven right now
until the resurrection what's the
purpose of the resurrection the people
are already there Jesus did say that he
you know would be returning to heaven so
to make a place for us so he says and if
I go I will come a very background
that's coming in handy for ya when Jesus
said I will go and prepare a place for
you John chapter 14 and if I go I will
come again and receive you to myself so
when is he coming you read in 1st
Thessalonians 4 the Lord Himself will
descend from heaven with a shout the
voice of the Archangel the Trump of God
then the dead in Christ will rise so
when the Lord comes also in 1st
Corinthians 15 the dead in Christ rise
the universal resurrection and the
judgment is still in the future if
everybody goes right to heaven or hell
when they die what good is a judgement
what good is a resurrection the reason
people get confused is because it is
true that for the person who dies their
next conscious thought is the
resurrection of life or death and their
reward because they have no
consciousness in death but it hasn't
happened yet because we're living in
time right now you is what I was
thinking about brother
Arceus bro who recently passed away and
the folks of Ligonier have repeatedly
mentioned now that you know he's with
the law or enjoying he's and he's with
the Lord and
you know enjoying the fruits of his
labor while he was with us here on earth
well now that's the met and you could
say I'm metaphorically that's true
for RC Sproule who have met he died in a
saved condition his next conscious
thought is and it'll seem like a moment
for him resurrection and the presence of
the Lord but we're living in a world of
time yet where that hasn't happened so
you kind of have to put yourself in
their shoes and say yeah they're next
conscious thought is the presence of the
Lord but he's not up in heaven looking
down you find nowhere in the Bible where
people in heaven are communicating with
people on earth other than the vision
here with Moses and Elijah hey you would
really enjoy I never thought that people
have in heaven would be looking down
they certainly have a lot better things
to do than to be concerned with what's
going on here on earth yeah but you
would enjoy and I hope you'll ask for
the free book that we're offering called
are the dead really dead matter of fact
there's a website out there called death
truth com it's got a lot of good
scripture on this subject people are so
confused you walk through a cemetery and
one grave says our mothers resting in
Jesus the next grave says our mothers
singing with the angels and people go
which is it you know so people need to
understand this because some folks you
know the Bible says don't talk to a
person who is a medium to communicate
with the dead we've got to know the
living know they'll die but the dead
know nothing jesus said our friend
Lazarus is asleep and I go wake him so
the dead are sleeping until the
resurrection and please request the free
book are the dead really dead Glenn or
anyone if you get questions about that
hey thank you very much we're gonna take
a couple more calls while time lingers
now I hope I can say this name right el
Vettes am I saying that right yes Evelyn
okay and your question tonight
I am good evening I am calling to ask
about recurring dreams in the Bible okay
you want to know if a dream keeps coming
back what does it mean right that's
interesting you would say that I almost
never have dreams I remember and I had
one today and I wondered if it had a
meaning but I'm not going to tell
everyone about that it's sort of between
me and the Lord but you know most of our
dreams are just the brain defragmenting
and there is a scripture on that in
Ecclesiastes it says a dream comes
through the multitude of business in
other words Solomon is saying if you
spend all day you know counting chickens
you might dream about chickens whatever
you're doing a lot of during the day you
may dream about because you're filling
your mind with it and it's not unusual
or if you're worrying about something
all day you may dream about it at night
but there are divine dreams and there
are the devil can give us a nightmare
and scare us so you can have good dreams
and bad dreams but most dreams are not
supernatural in nature okay and what if
the recurring dream has to do with real
events that are happening in your life
well God could try and you know God
speaks to us through dreams he spoke to
Joseph the son of Jacob God spoke to
Joseph the father of Jesus through
dreams God spoke to Daniel through
dreams so God can communicate doesn't
mean they're all you know divine
utterance it might be a little message
from God to us I don't know I don't have
that gift of interpretation of dreams
like Daniel and Joseph did so God could
be trying to tell you something and it
could just be your mind worrying you
because you're thinking about something
I don't know
so the scriptures like I said the
Scriptures tell us God does speak
through dreams in the book of Job the
devil frightened job with a dream vision
and Solomon said dreams typically come
through the multitude of business just
the stuff that we think about during the
day no supernatural meaning to it
surely I hope that helps a little bit
hey thank you for your question we're
gonna try and squeeze in one more while
time remains and we're gonna talk with
Diana
who's calling from South Carolina
listening on line six Diana are you
there are Diana hi we got just about
three minutes your question okay I I was
a double a dual parent I raised my two
children because we were exiled from
where we used to live so we didn't have
parents my parents or anybody but it was
me and those two children right my son
is now a officer in the Marine Corps
he's married several years and he's got
four children now his oldest is eight he
has three daughters we're gonna run out
of time together you probably got to
jump to the question or we may not have
time for an answer the girls the way he
wants them to be dressed but he wants me
to dress that same way even though
that's not in my character you know I
dress conservatively but I don't dress
that way so in in his way of judging me
he says I should not be as a grandmother
I should not be a part of the girls the
children's life because he does not see
that if I don't dress the way he says I
should I'm not supporting him and his
wife in their parenting song all right
so the question is does your this is
your son-in-law have a right to ask you
to dress a certain way my thought is
your son okay you know okay of course
biblically the Bible says kids should
honor their parents then there's a Bible
principle that says don't do anything
that will make someone else stumble and
Paul said you know I become all things
to all people that I might win some to
Christ so you know if it means
living peacefully with someone when
you're with them or you're visiting the
children I would say you know try to
accommodate them as much as you can if
it's not going to hurt and it protects
the relationship even if they're maybe
asking you something that's extreme if
you want you can put your foot down it
might become you know a point of contest
and you've what you'd hate to be cut off
from the children or grandchildren so
I'll pray God gives you wisdom that is a
difficult challenge hey friends thank
you so much for your Bible questions it
seems like this hour just zooms on by we
do have some important announcements
coming I want to remind you that a lot
of what amazing facts has to offer is
available through the week at the
website go check out amazing facts dot
o-r-g there's videos there are books
there there's all kinds of streaming
audio god bless you and have a blessed
New Year
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture the Egyptians built pyramids to
help guide the spirits of their leaders
Rome sanctioned holidays to honor and
appease the spirits of their dead even
the Bible tells of a king that used a
witch to contact the spirit of a
deceased prophet today ancient folklore
of spirits and apparitions have gone
from mere superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality scientific
organisations investigate stories of
hauntings and sightings trying to prove
once and for all the existence of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world there is still no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true
why do these stories persist does it
even matter we invite you to look inside
and find out for yourself visit death
truth dot-com if you'd like to enhance
your study of God's Word visit our
website at WWF Axew RG and sign up for
our free Bible study course and make
sure to check out our online bookstore
at AF bookstore com which offers
thousands of inspiring books DVDs and
more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at
[Music]